President Obama loved having I think he
had a blackberry and they took it away
from him when he became president they
said you can't have it it's a security
risk and it was a great frustration that
he couldn't have you know his his
smartphone with the mers device our
current president is tweeting non-stop
how do you feel about that well I I
would like to say to Ivanka and Eric and
Donald Jr if you're watching please take
the keys away from dad he should not be
driving the Twitter mobile right we
certainly shouldn't be driving it
without adult supervision
yeah because those tweets have caused
enormous damage I mean that that Twitter
feed he had yeah where he accused his
predecessor of gross illegality and and
felonious conduct and then interspersed
criticism of Arnold Schwarzenegger
ratings right that has led to untold
damage you had when he couldn't find any
corroboration of this him blamed the
British and suggest well maybe British
intelligence was spying for Obama on me
and the Brits had to say
that's nonsense with the British are
among our best intelligence partners
right right all because he was yes I
have a question can I ask a question I
was very excited that you were gonna be
here I have a question in the comment
what you spent more time setting this up
Kumail then actually asked ok now I've
added more time to that go ahead okay
when I walk with you I'm going to be
looking out for birds above question is
what's gonna happen and the comment is
help what's gonna happen I don't know I
don't know what's gonna happen and like
a kid that can't get to sleep yeah
what's gonna happen drink some warm milk
gonna think about your birthday and
you'll fall asleep
you